في نفس اليوم الذي كشف فيه الرئيس المنتخب جو بايدن
عن خطته للتصدي للوباء
بمجرد توليه منصبه ، حذر مركز السيطرة
على الأمراض من الأمريكيين الذين
حذروا الأمريكيين من
متغير فيروس كورونا شديد العدوى
الذي يقول إنه قد يؤدي إلى تفاقم انتشاره في الولايات المتحدة
، وتتوقع الوكالة أيضًا
عدد القتلى الأمريكيين من  يمكن أن يتجاوز الوباء
400000 قبل أن يؤدي جو بايدن اليمين في يوم
الأربعاء القادم ويقترب بشدة حيث
نتحدث في هذا فقط في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
تم الإبلاغ عن نصف مليون حالة وفاة جديدة بفيروس كورونا
في الأسابيع الستة الماضية فقط.
أخصائي الطب الباطني والفيروسات ، دعونا نتحدث
عن هذا البديل الجديد
إذا كان بإمكاننا نقله بسهولة أكبر ،
فما الذي
يفعله ذلك بجهود الولايات المتحدة لمكافحة
الوباء جيدًا لأنه يجعل الأمر أكثر
صعوبة في المقام الأول إنه
طفرات  يحدث طوال الوقت وهذا
البديل من إنجلترا وهناك
آخرون في جميع أنحاء العالم
يجعل الفيروس أكثر فاعلية
لذلك فهو  فيروس أكثر صحة
ما سيحدث
كما تنبأ مركز السيطرة على الأمراض بأن هذا
سيكون الفيروس السائد
بحلول شهر مارس من هذا العام هو أن المزيد من
الناس
من المرجح جدًا أن يصابوا
الآن ، وكلما زاد عدد الإصابات حتى لو
بقيت نسبة الوفيات
كما هي.  زيادة عدد الوفيات ، زيادة
عدد الأشخاص الذين سيذهبون
إلى المستشفى
للمرض ، مما يعني أن عددًا أقل من
الأشخاص الذين يمكنهم الوصول إلى الرعاية
من الأمراض الأخرى ، لذلك سيؤدي ذلك إلى زيادة
العبء على نظام الرعاية الصحية.
عدد الوفيات وسوف
ينشر المرض
بشكل أسرع في جميع أنحاء البلاد ،
نعم إنه أمر مروع نظرًا لما
نحن فيه الآن ومسؤولو الصحة العامة المحليون
في المكان الذي تتواجد فيه في مقاطعة هناك
شخص يموت كل ست دقائق من
الطمع 19.
ماذا  يجعل هذه المتغيرات الجديدة
أكثر سهولة في الانتقال
بشكل جيد وببساطة شديدة أريد من الناس أن يفكروا
في الفيروس على أنه عقد يحتوي على
ست خرزات ملونة فقط دعنا نقول وهناك  هي
عبارة عن حبة صفراء حبة حمراء ذات نمط معين
أيا كان
عندما يتكاثر الفيروس وعن طريق الخطأ
تأتي حبة ملونة
مختلفة تغير البنية الكاملة
للفيروس
ويمكن أن تجعله هذه البنية أكثر فاعلية على
سبيل المثال الاختلاف الإنجليزي
لهذا الفيروس يجعله
التعلق أكثر فاعلية ، لذا فإن
هذا الفيروس فعال للغاية في
نقله ، وهذا ما يجعله
أكثر خطورة ، ما نأمله
هو عدم وجود طفرة في المستقبل
تجعل الفيروس محصنًا ضد
اللقاحات الحالية ،
لذا فهو فيروس أكثر فاعلية.
ستنتشر بسهولة أكبر
في المجتمع